I just want to give a quick intro my
name is Horry uproots you I'm a
developer advocate at IBM and I've been
focusing on the blockchain platform
for the last eight eight or nine months
here and as part of my job and I doing
some workshops I do some a sample coding
I do show developers how to easily get
started with this technology and today I
want to walk you through some getting
started with hypervisor
so both the open source just local
technology but also want to show you a
little preview of the cloud service that
IBM provides for the blockchain awesome
so yep let's go ahead and dive right in
okay so if you need to find my slides
again you can find them on my Twitter
page
they should be pinned right at the top
and so I'll have some links in here to
my my code it's all on github and then
all the concepts of course you can view
later to see my actual twitter handle is
just this at Horry uproots you it will
be on the bottom of every page okay so
the agenda today first I will just talk
a little bit about what is hyper ledger
and after that I want to show you how to
download and get started on your local
computer so I'll show you where you can
download all the hyper ledger fabric
I'll show you you there will be some
scripts you have to run to actually
start the fabric on a computer so I'll
go ahead and do that too and then I'll
show you this hello world or just your
first smart contract so hopefully you
can at least get some sort of knowledge
of how to deploy your first contract so
after I do that I'll show you this proof
of concept I've built using the
blockchain cloud service and kind of
show you why I built it
kind of how it compares to this hello
world application so I'm trying to kind
of bridge that gap is like this hello
world and then take you to the next step
of a little bit of more complex
application okay so with the show of
hands how many know about hyper ledger
in this room okay this is good nice so
how about blockchain who's familiar with
blockchain somewhat okay so more most
most people okay
so hyper ledger is this open source
project under the Linux Foundation and
and what you see here at the top is we
have all the frameworks so there's
fabric is the most mature framework and
they have this way of grading of how
much sure the project is so there's a
hyper ledger borough
there's fabric indie Aroha and sawtooth
so today I will focus on fabric so IBM
is one of the main contributors to
fabric so I'll focus on that what you
see on this picture is you see the
channel support for fabric so that's one
of the main features of fabric is this
channels and I'll show you that as part
of my demo
and composer you see right under the
frameworks you have these tools and
today I'll talk about a tool called
composer and this composer is just
simply taking the complexities away of
developing with hyper larger fabric so
it's just trying to make this
development a bit easier and they have
their own modeling language and they
have smart contracts based on JavaScript
so I'll show that's what I'll be mostly
focusing on today is this hyper ledger
composer okay so one question I get very
frequently when I do this talk is what
is the difference between hyper ledger
fabric and hyper ledger composer so
again this main thing I want you to
under
is that fabric is always necessary but
composure just accesses fabric in a
easy-to-use manner so composure is
optional but I think it's a really good
way to get started developing and under
the hood composers really just calling
the fabric api's and it's it's it's it's
really just building on top of fabric so
some of the key concepts that we will
learn about is participants transactions
and assets so these are the key words
that I'll mostly be focusing on today
and that's the key words that composer
uses okay so here's the link for
actually downloading the fabric
environment for your local computer of
course I don't recommend doing this now
because it will take some time to
actually download but I'm after if you
want to go home and try this out I leave
this link here for you
so um once you actually download the
fabric on your local computer you'll
have some scripts that you'll need to
run or the first one is download fabric
so I've already done that on my computer
and that was just taking the actual
fabric and putting it on your computer
the start fabric script is what I will
show you later today in my demo and
that's gonna create some containers and
the four containers that will create one
will be a database one will be order one
will be a peer and one will be a
certificate authority so I'll kind of go
a little bit more about that when I
actually run the script and the last
thing we have to do is actually create
these pure admin card this is the
credentials that will give us these are
the credentials that is basically admin
access to the network so we have to
prove with our public private key pair
that we are the admins of the network
and that's what this script is doing is
creating these credentials for us
so um I talked a little bit about this
modeling language so this is a composer
uses this unique modeling language and
their file is called this model file so
that's just really the data schema of
your actual application so the four
things we really have to worry about is
the namespace the participants the
assets and the transactions so we have
to define these four core features the
events are optional I will not show that
for the sake of time but know that there
is events as well so this is basically
what you will need to define and I think
this is really the most critical part of
building your application is this model
file so if if you spend most of your
time actually coming up with a very good
model I think that is really the key to
a successful blockchain application so
really take the time I think really to
understand who are your participants in
your blockchain network and what
transactions and assets
do you have but really the participants
is at the core right we want to ensure
that you know we are we we have some
value being traded on the blockchain so
again this this first part of defining
the model is is I think the key and the
most important part so here I have a
very simple kind of like a hello world
model file so this model file I will
show you deploying this with composer
and as part of the demo so first thing
we have our namespace at the top in that
after that everything we want to
reference in the blockchain will be
coming from this main space so once we
have defined our main namespace we can
define our asset so we see here we just
have a very generic asset called
commodity and we have five different
fields for this asset so you see we have
three strings we have the trading symbol
the description and the main exchange
and we have a double and then the really
key part is this arrow notation you see
and that's simply just a reference to a
different part of the box chain so we're
referencing a trader here so right under
our asset we have defined our trader so
what that arrow is saying is that every
commodity has to have a trader so again
we have our asset under that we define
our participant so we have this trader
and you see here we have this identified
by so a lot of times when you're working
with blockchain you'll want to query a
particular participant or an asset and
see exactly what has happened to this
asset as it has moved along the
blockchain so to do that you have this
unique identifier this trade ID and you
can query by this trade ID and then see
kind of what has happened to this asset
as it goes across the blockchain and I
can show you that in a little bit here
the last part is the actual transaction
and this is something we actually have
to implement so this is a very simple
changing of ownership so you see this
transaction takes a commodity and it
takes a trader and you see here that for
trader we have this new owner so all
we're doing is we're taking a reference
to the asset and we're taking a
reference to the trader and we're just
updating that owner so I've shown you
the data schema here next I'll show you
the implementation of this transaction
called trade so here is the
implementation so this is the actual
smart contract may be referred as chain
code and hyper ledger terms typewriter
fabric terms so you see here this is
written in JavaScript you see we have
some promises and so that is something
you'll have to be familiar with to
develop this smart contract so the first
thing we do is just assign our actual
new owner to the
commodity and what's important from this
slide is this get asset registry so this
is the composer API so that's basically
taking this namespace the or ahmed my
network dot commodity and it's going
into the blockchain and getting that
actual asset and then once we actually
get it we have this update api right and
it's just going to simply update what
data we have given it so all we're doing
here is taking this new owner and
updating the owner field of the
commodity so this is kind of your hello
world just changing changing the owner
so as we talked about earlier there's
some kind of this conflict with these
public blockchain networks and this
private network so kind of like we the
MC is talking earlier this etherium has
this kind of conflict so the access
control rules is really what makes this
network private or permissioned so these
these rules here is where you can
specify who in your network has access
to what so by default we have a very
simple like everyone has access to
everything so in a more complex scenario
you want to have reference certain
participants and say they only have read
access maybe some different participants
have write access so this is where you
will do that and this is kind of this
private or permissioned architecture so
what i've shown you so far is this data
schema i've shown you the actual
javascript implementation the chain code
and then i've shown you this security
access control rules so these are the
three main files that composer works
with to create your business network so
once we create this business network we
will have a rest api that we can deploy
and we will be able to access the
blockchain with our api so our api will
have
exactly what is defined in the data
schema so it will have our asset it will
have our trader and it will have our
trade transaction and we'll be able to
post we'll be able to get we'll be able
to put so that's what what this goal for
deploying this network is coming up with
this API and after you do that you can
simply hook up this API with your
front-end code and basically update the
network that way just with using this
this API okay so and this is where
composer comes in so once you finish
developing these three files and you
have this command called composer
archive create and this basically zips
up your three files into one and file
nothing complex here and and this file
is called the Business Network archive
some referred to as a banana file DNA
banana so and that's that's really what
composer is doing it's taking these
three files that we have defined and
creating this one Business Network
archive this one zipped file and to
actually deploy the network we have to
have some credentials so that's where
these network admin card comes in and we
have a script for creating these
credentials so once we have our banana
file we have our credentials and we can
actually deploy our REST API then we'll
have a nice swagger has this nice
documentation for the REST API which
I'll show you in a minute dear okay so
for the sake of time I'll leave this for
later but this is an online playground
where you can go ahead and test your
code so without installing any dev tools
on your laptop you can go ahead and take
the C code I've shown you here and
deploy it there and do some transactions
and see the owners being updated so this
is I think a nice tool just to test
quickly your smart contracts
okay so time for the demo here okay so
basically what I have done so what you
see here is this github and so this is
called the code pattern so part of my
job at IBM is creating these open-source
code patterns to help developers on
board with the technology so this is one
my coworker created but I think this is
a really good way to get started and
this is kind of the code that is in this
repo is what I have just shown on the
slides so it's the exact same code and
here you'll have all the scripts that I
talked about the start fabric the
download fabric the Create Pier admin
card you have all the scripts in this
nice repository so I'll go through some
of these steps and at the end we'll
we'll create this REST API okay
so what's nice about this github it
gives you a nice diagram of what exactly
will be doing so first we install the
dev tools I'm going to skip that step
just for time then we're actually
generating the fabric network and we're
starting the fabric and then we are
basically just generating this banana
file and we're deploying it and we're
creating this local API local server so
that's that deployment is step five
there so we have a few prerequisites
here and just I'm not going to go
through those here but the main tool
you'll need to install is this composer
CLI so that's what I'll be using to
package this three main files into our
DNA or banana file and then the last
tool and this composer rest server and
this just has some some code to create
this nice-looking
rest API documentation so this composer
rest server
package is basically just creating this
nice REST API for us okay
so the first thing we should do is
actually start our earth so first we
just clone the directory I've done that
for now and now let's go ahead and go
into okay so you see here the same code
I've shown you earlier so we're in our
actual directory here so first thing we
want to do I'll I'll just delete these
cards from the floor clear and then
we'll start the fabric so this will take
a little bit of time here but what you
see at the bottom is these containers
being stopped and then they will be
restarted again and they'll be running
so the four things that I've mentioned
before is the the database the CouchDB
the order that'll take all the
transactions and actually place them in
some sort of order the peer the peer
will be running the smart contract on it
and generating some sort of output and
then the actual certificate authority
that will give out the public private
key pairs to the participants so we see
here that we have started our network
everything looks good so far so the demo
gods are with me right now so next we
want to actually create our admin
credentials so we have this create peer
admin card so this in a second we'll
create these credentials for us so you
see here we have this peer admin at
hyper letter fabric version 1 that's our
actual card here so now we have created
our credentials now we actually need to
use this composer archive create to
package our three files into something
we can deploy so the nice thing about
this repo is it automates all of that
for us
so if we go into our package JSON we can
see this composer archive create here
and all it's doing is it's taking are
all the three files in our directory and
it's taking that data schema it's taking
the lot of the JavaScript code that
logic and it's taking the permission
files and we give it a directory to put
those files in and we say dist slash
mind at work DNA that's where you will
output this file so again just to show
you these separate files I have the
JavaScript implementation or what I've
shown earlier I have the actual data
schema and then the actual permissions
file same exact thing so if I run npm
install now it should create this actual
banana file in my current in this disk
directory so i'll run npm install so
hopefully in a couple seconds here we
should get this nice output so we see
again we have this output file dist
slash my network DNA so we'll need to
give that file to composer to compose a
rest server to actually deploy our api
ok so after that there's some additional
things we can do I'm not gonna test for
the sake of time but we have some tests
in here and then we can actually install
the network so this is the key part and
it's taking in my actual admin card and
it's taking my banana file and it's
installing the network here on the pier
ok so I'll go ahead and run this we see
that the command succeeded so now we've
installed the network and the next thing
we have to do is actually instantiate
the network so we have to start the
network and if there's any sort of
constructor any sort of data that we
build and the at the start of the
network this is when that will happen so
let's go ahead and start the network
here ok
so should take a couple seconds here we
give our admin card we give our like our
net yeah our admin card and then
basically we'll start the network for us
it will we should see yeah okay so we
start the network we can actually ping
the network to see if it's working I'll
not do that right now so the next thing
we can do is actually create our API so
let's go ahead and run this compose a
rest server so this will ask okay clear
so this will ask us for our actual
business network card so that will be
the admin card we have made earlier
so admin at my network and here ask for
namespaces if you say yes it will have
the org Acme dot commodity I'm gonna say
no for making it look a little nicer so
we'll just say commodity instead of org
doc made my network the commodity so
I'll say never and I'm not gonna secure
it for now just for the sake of time so
ask do you want to enable authentication
and okay so I'm just gonna say no for
now so it's going to go into the types
of our network and now we've generated
our REST API if we click this we should
see our REST API here so again we have
the commodity if we we don't have any
commodities created yet because our
constructor didn't create any and but if
we this is where we can go ahead and do
like a get call and then we would see
all the commodities in our network
that's this system is like the entire
history of the blockchain so for the
system now we should just see something
like a install we see the network is
instantiated and I believe just the the
basically just the first installation so
let's check that right now
yes you see here we have the start of
the network and then we have added the
actual admin here so what I can do I can
actually add a couple traders here I'm
not going to go through the full a flow
for time but I can add a couple traders
and all of this JSON that we need is in
the repo so here is the data schema for
the trader I'll just create once quickly
I'll post it here and if we try it it
should give us hopefully two hundred
awesome so we see here the date and if
we go into our system we should have
this as well okay perfect so we have
this add participant we say we see that
we add min invoked it so that's what we
have with the system record so this is
how you get your first hello world
application running once you have this
API running you can go ahead and connect
to your front-end and then you can have
this whole history of transactions you
can have more complex queries I haven't
shown that but I'll show this in the
next demo so you have more complex
queries but this is kind of the basics
of getting started just getting to this
point so now I want to switch gears a
little bit so you can kind of see this
shirt I'm wearing is this blockchain IBM
blockchain in collaboration with
Brooklyn roasting so this is a proof of
concept I've worked on using the
blockchain cloud service so I want to
kind of demo and show you that now so I
want to show this hello world and then
going to a little bit more complex
architecture and schema now okay so
close this up from now okay
okay so this is the main page for the
[Music]
for the activation so really the goal of
this project was to show this
transparency for all the key suppliers
in the supply chain so if the goal of
Brooklyn roasting company so this is the
partner we worked with their goal is to
show this ethically and sustainably
produced coffee so part of that mission
is showing this fair fair price that is
paid for the coffee
so what we should what we have here in
this project is we have their actual
industry compliant documentation that
shows that they gave a fair wage to the
coffee growers that they paid and we
have shipping details such as like a
packing list
we have import details and then we have
actual roast details so before the the
coffee is actually brewed and created
into a cup of coffee the Brooklyn
roasting company goes ahead and taste
tests it critiques it says oh it's maybe
not so good or it's really good so those
are the main kind of components so again
I think what's important to understand
with block chain is that really 99% of
the work and investment comes as you're
creating the network once the network is
deployed and out there there's not
really much to be done right but it's a
huge massive investment to actually get
it started right you have to get all the
different parties all the different
suppliers agreed on the same exact terms
you have to actually you know build the
network like we have done here you takes
a lot of time and investment right once
you actually launch and deploy it's not
not that much work so I think that's the
key part is do we need a bot chain and
then actually taking the time to work
with all the participants and suppliers
involved and say hey are you okay with
these exact rules that
have gone by in this smart contract and
at the end of the day someone needs to
approve all these transactions right so
there has to be someone either an
external organization or someone that
you give permission to actually approve
these transactions so there's something
called like an endorsement policy which
you can set up in your hyper ledger and
saying which member is actually going to
approve the transaction is how do we
know it's actually you know a correct or
incorrect transaction okay so for the
next ten ten eleven minutes I want to
focus on the different participants in
different parties involved so the first
party I'll talk about is the actual
grower so the grower is this Ethiopia
co-op and we see here on July 21st 2017
we buy a hundred fifty bags of this
coffee so at this point a Brooklyn
roasting has a document that says look
when we bought these bags of coffee we
have given this tax to actually invest
in the local community and this is their
way of proving this Fairtrade premium so
if I click on view the blockchain and it
should actually query my blockchain and
it will show me exactly what has been
invested so we see that they have
invested in road infrastructure let me a
little bit we see they've invested in
road infrastructure they've invested in
school classrooms and food security also
you can see that the total premium they
have invested is 180 mm so you may be
thinking right now like okay this is
just random data where are you getting
this data from right it's like you're
just showing these data so now we can
click on the view original document so
Brooklyn roasting was nice enough to
actually let us publicize these
documents so what you can see here is
this a premium invested 180 mm exactly
what I've shown you earlier
you have the school classroom edition
the funds invested 30,000 you have the
road infrastructure and the food
security so these are some of the fields
we thought were important and Brooklyn
roasting thought were important to show
to the all the customers the different
suppliers so this is the way of showing
this fair trade and ethically produced
and sustainable coffee so we have talked
about the first part of our journey
which is the grower so next we will have
to actually ship this big very huge
batch of coffee I'm not sure it may be a
thousand kilos or a very big amount we
ship this from Ethiopia to the United
States so now we need some sort of proof
from the shipper that you know we have
packages all your coffee on this date
shipped it in this container you'll
it'll arrive on this date we have we
have to have some documents here so
that's the next part of the story here
so we can go back and and just to show
you kind of my actual API that's running
so this is the API that I have available
for this this coffee bean demo so this
is the same HelloWorld API but just with
a little bit more complex data schema so
instead of only one participant I have
four four or five participants so we
have the grower we have the shipper we
have the retailer right so it's really
that same pretty much that same thing
just added a little more complexity to
the schema so if I actually go in to
submit Fairtrade data so you can think
of this as we have a different interface
for this grower we have they have their
own application they sign in they
authenticate and they have access to
this rest endpoint and they're able to
submit our Brookland it will actually
submit this Fairtrade data through this
endpoint and only they can submit this
data so we get we we actually do a get
here to see what's actually so has been
submitted already
so again it's that same exact data that
was showing in that front end right it's
really just doing a simple get call to
this so you can see again the road
infrastructure here the food security
classroom addition we have the some more
data that was not shown in the UI like
the actual batch ID so you can imagine
if there's 100 or 200 different
huge batches of coffee we each one will
have this unique ID so you can actually
see the process for each bag ok so yeah
when you click on this view the
blockchain it's just making a call to my
API that's running in the cloud right
now so second step here is we have to
show these packing details so again I
should I tell you you know we have to
have some data for actually shipping so
this is the next step here
so we click on view the blockchain and
now we should see some more details
about the packing list so you can see
the voyage number the invoice number
something interesting is that this has a
reference to the grower so you're saying
who actually gave these beams to be
shipped you're saying grower 0 2 0 1 so
you're saying okay who's grower 0 2 0 1
if we actually go into our our REST API
if we go into grower do a get we should
see our growers 0 2 0 wand ok and you
see here that's just simply the
Ethiopian co-op right so we see here
that's who is actually submitting these
beans and you see here that who's
actually going to receive the beans so
this is this trader oops there's trader
0 7 9 1 so okay if we go into trader
we'll see who the who's actually picking
up the beans do a get and we'll see that
here
yeah yeah so I was already loaded so you
see Royal coffee was actually receiving
these beans okay again we see the ship
name northern Magnum Magnum and we see
the bill of landing number 961 so we can
view the original document same same
thing this is all coming from the the
coffee co-op so this is their proof that
we have actually shipped this data or
this this batch on this day so we see
the date is 2017
this Royal coffee bill of landing number
again you see that nine six one number
and you see the container number is is a
blocked out that's just part of our
agreement with Brooklyn roasting they
didn't want to show that to detail just
for security purposes but everything
else they have lettuce demin show
publicly so you see here that container
number is redacted just for security
purposes okay so we've shipped the
coffee next thing about how long does
this journey take two weeks two and a
half weeks two and half weeks later we
actually receive the container so now we
have to go into the container and see
like did we actually get the amount of
coffee that was shipped or is there
damage is there did it spoil over the
ocean is there insects you know we have
to confirm that we got a good shipment
so we can view the blockchain here again
it's just calling my REST API here so we
see you know are there holes in
container no was there any condensations
how many bags do we expect it was the
insect activity and that again that
document is just coming straight from
this importer and they're the one that
is actually receiving the shipment and
you can imagine this big importer of
coffee has you know thousands of shipler
i don't know in a in a normal month
maybe they have hundreds of these
shipments right so we have to have good
organization to keep track of all of
these again you see on this
documentation the bags expected you know
condensation holes in container we have
people that I've actually signed off on
this thing look this is what happened on
this date we verified it and that's just
coming again straight from this submit
inbound wait tally here okay yeah so
same exact info here that you see on the
front end okay so the last step which I
think is really the coolest part is this
cupping so once they the retailer buys
this coffee from this big warehouse they
go ahead and critique so you can imagine
like I don't know ten of these coffee
connoisseurs sitting around sipping a
little bit Oh aftertaste is not so good
or it's too acidic but the taste is it's
good but it's maybe not perfect so they
have their own internal critiquing
system so this is what you'll see with
this part of the blockchain you'll see
who actually this Brian actually
critiqued it what was his final score
and you see above that you know aroma
nine you know it this is all out of ten
nine out of ten acidity eight out of ten
flavor eight out of ten same thing we
have this original document to show this
here okay again same same thing you see
Brian the realm of the flavor we have
some more descriptors like it tastes
like blueberry a little bit lime honey
okay
so the last part that I want to show you
is this this actual your cup of coffee
so what we did at this it was this big
food festival so what happened is every
cup had this barcode on and basically
one use when you buy it or buy a cup or
you know go up to get a cup of coffee
the barista or the retailer will scan
this cup and when they scan the cup
there just simply calling my arrest
and they're posting to the blockchain so
they're saying look at this exact time
and date I've sold this cup of coffee to
this person and we say you know I have
you know Brian was the one that sold it
the drink was iced coffee served at this
time we have all this information and
maybe this is not maybe necessary in a
real worse scenario but we thought this
would be a good way to show some of
additional functionality so now let me
show you the cloud service running so
this is the IBM blockchain starter plan
so if right now if you sign up you
should get a month free to develop so
right now you'll see my channel right
now I only have one channel if I wanted
to create different channels I can do
that and basically I'll have private
transactions within each channel so it's
almost like a blockchain within a block
chain kind of this is what fabric offers
so again we have our blocks here we see
the last time is 50 minutes ago so I'll
post a new cup and in a couple seconds
here you should see it posted to the
block I so does anyone have a random
number three digit number what's six six
okay I'll try that maybe not the best
thing to do but I'll put that in so we
should see this new block being added so
it should be 721 we should see that 666
ID into the blockchain now and once I do
this I get once it's successfully in the
blockchain I can query and I can show
this relevant details so again you see
this you know 15 seconds to the last
transaction to 721 blocks in a second
here we should see the details of this
block and we should see that 666 number
right here so yeah you can see it so now
we can query the blockchain for that
specific number so you can imagine I
have just gone got
a cup of coffee and say I go home and I
say okay I want to see the history of
where this cup of coffee came from so
here I put in my cup of coffee and a
couple seconds we'll get all that detail
so we'll get the exact time so it's
today 1208 you know this is the type of
drink this is your cup ID and the type
of beams you have in the roaster and
then you have the full timeline after
that like okay this is where the cup
came from but where did those beams
actually come from right and you have
this timeline and that's exactly what I
showed you previously is this history of
exactly where the beam came from so I'm
running out of time here but maybe I'll
show you one more minute of the code and
then I will be out of here so the last
thing I'll show you is this blockchain
beam code so this is online I will give
you the repo name at the end so I'll
show you the code here so again I think
the most important part is the model
file so this is what we have here we
have are all of our different
participants I showed you we have the we
did talk about regulator but we have
grower trader shipper retailer we have
our cup of coffee this is what I show
you earlier we have the cup ID we have
the drink type barista this is the
schema for it and then you have this big
batch of coffee where you have multiples
cups of coffee coming from so this is
where you actually put the data for the
Fairtrade premium the packing list the
weight tally this is where the
conditions come in and then the my
favorite part is tasting the cupping
details how good it tastes right so this
is the coffee asset the big batch and
then and what I showed you earlier is
this poor cup this transaction poor cup
it just takes in a cup ID and it
generates this time stamp for us right
and that's more or less it and that's
the schema and then the actual logic is
is here I can show you a simple one so
basically all we do is we get our actual
coffee from the blockchain so
we get this asset registry as I showed
you before is this composer API and then
we just set all the fields of the coffee
so we set the invoice number we set the
bill of landing number we set the loader
vessel and then after we create an event
I didn't show that but at the end we
just update and that's pretty much it
okay so I will leave you with that so
here are all the all the things I have
just shown you the github czar all here
if you want my actual if you have any
questions here is my contact info and
basically what I showed you today is how
to get started with this hyper ledger
fabric so there's this local open-source
you can install on your computer test
locally but you will not get this nice
UI to actually inspect all these you can
still do this inspection but you know we
have this nice UI you could create
different channels so I've shown you the
open-source version I showed you a
little taste of the cloud version as
well so hopefully you understand now
this data schema is really that most
important part of creating this this
network and then basically implementing
a few transactions there on the network
so I've shown you that and I've shown
you this a proof of concept we are built
with Brooklyn roasting which is taking
some of their supply chain data and for
the purpose of showing all of their
suppliers more efficient and streamlined
process to show ok I this second I've
received this document we have shown
exactly what time we received it we've
signed off on it so increasing this
transparency for both the customers and
the suppliers and then just for fun
every time we actually gave a cup of
coffee we added on watching to so
hopefully you have learned at least
something about hyper ledger and thank
you so much for your time
[Applause]